mistral or historical character that's
been found by a designation and when in
making a determination about whether a
building does qualify for landmark
status the Commission hold a public
hearing like this one and to consider
the testimony of all interested parties
the owner of the property in question
the public that's here today elected
officials citizens everyone and that's
why I'm gratified that there is a turn
out like this and we look forward to the
proceedings and I am aware that this
designation has proposed designation has
generated a lot of discussion about the
property and its potential use or
current user future use and let me
emphasize that in deciding whether to
designate the building this building or
any other building the Commission is
required here's our standard to require
to determine whether the building in
question and here I quote from the
landmarks law quote has a special
character or special historical or
aesthetic interest or value as part of
the development heritage or cultural
characteristics of new york city new
york state or the nation god bless
issues regarding how this building or
any other site or is used are not
relevant to this proceeding of those
determinations so again this is the
second step of the formal process
there's a calendaring there's a public
hearing and then ultimately there is a
vote a decision by the Commission to
designate or not to designate and this
building Renaissance italian palazzo
style building constructed circa 1857
1858 the question would be whether it
has the special architectural cultural
again quoting the statue or restore
characteristics that would warrant
designation so i want to again thank you
all for being here thank President
jennifer RAB one of my distinguished
predecessors as chair of the Landmarks
Commission the president of Hunter
College he was up here a moment ago to
greet us she
has very graciously allowed us to
utilize this space today and has given
us the opportunity to work with hunt
that her staff in Hunter College and our
staff at the Landmarks Commission many
of whom are here today to ensure that we
have a smooth proceeding so I want to
again thank Jennifer and everybody at
Hunter they've been remarkable and I
greatly appreciate it and now I'm going
to turn over as we always do at this
stage of the public hearings turn over
to Mary Beth bets to my left the
director of research at the Landmarks
Preservation Commission who will provide
a brief presentation about some of the
reasons why 45 part plays may merit
designation that's in other words why I
was calendared what presumptive or
threshold tests were met to even bring
us to this stage and at that point after
that's concluded we'll begin calling
people up to these two microphones to
testify Mary death good afternoon
commissioners the item before us for
proposed for public hearing is LP 24-34
45 to 47 Park Place building at 45 to 47
Park Place Manhattan the landmarks site
is borough of Manhattan tax map block
126 lot 9 in part consisting of the
portion of the lot bounded by a line
beginning at the southeastern corner of
a lot running westerly along the
southern lot line 54 and 5 inches to the
southwestern corner of the 45 47 Park
Place building this northerly along the
exterior of the western wall of said
building and parallel with the easterly
side of west broadway to the northern
lot line thence easterly along the
northern lot line to the eastern lot
line then southerly along the eastern
lot line to the point of beginning
completed in 1857 258 this five-story
store and loft building is a fine
example of the Italian Renaissance
inspired palazzi that flourished from
the 1850s through the 1870s in the
former textile and dry goods district on
and around broadway near city hall park
it was constructed for paul Spofford and
thomas Tillotson proprietors at one of
the city's most prominent shipping firms
as you can see on the map while number
45 to 47 Park Place shares a large tax
lot with another building only 45 to 47
Park Place is being considered for
landmark designation by drawing upon the
architectural vocabulary of the Italian
Renaissance Palazzo the builders of
mercantile structures like 45 to 47 Park
Place sought to project an image of
prestige and economic power the building
retains much of its historic fabric
including its original ground floor
Corinthian colonnade cast by Daniel D
Badger and company it's stone-faced
upper floors appear much as they did
when the building opened featuring
molded window surrounds molded
projecting lentils bracketed sills and
second floor balcony with faux turned
balusters flanking the building simple
continuous cornice are two scrolled
brackets it also retains many of its
historic likely original 2 / 2 double
hung windows although their glazing has
been painted alterations include the
replacement of its storefront infill and
the installation of a metal fire escape
which probably dates from the early 20th
century okay thank you very much married
back and now a couple quick housekeeping
if you will details before we get
started the owner of the building has
the prerogative as we customarily at the
commission to testify first or in the
middle or at the end whatever he or she
or it shall choose and and they are
going to have elected to testify first
and i'll call them in a moment and then
go right to public
members of the public elected officials
and others who are here and who sign up
and to the extent possible call everyone
in the order in which the signup
occurred and again there we have a three
minute and I hope everyone will listen
carefully and abide by the proposed
three-minute rule and if possible two
minutes whatever you can do and we will
notify everyone with a shout out of some
kind modest when the three minutes has
expired and hopefully everyone the more
people adhere to that rule the more
people have the opportunity to speak and
we're going to I'll be calling people up
in groups of five roughly we'll see how
this works out go to the mics have the
testimony call more people and sort of
work through it that way and I ask that
anybody who goes to the mics to speak
will state your name clearly for the
record so we're transcribing all this of
course and want an official record and
after you've spoken clear the aisle as
it were and we are here again through
that the sufferance of Hunter College we
have the auditorium and from two to five
three full hours we will hopefully get a
lot done during that time we'll have a
lot of information and a lot of people
to listen to a lot of points of view and
looking forward to it and at five when
we begin to wind down and close the
hearing for today we will keep open the
record on this matter because of its
significant importance of the issue and
we'll keep it open that record for until
the close of business next Tuesday July
twentieth so that anyone who either
hasn't had a chance for whatever reason
today or because of the weather wasn't
able to get here anything like that will
be encouraged or an are encouraged to
submit written testimony comes part of
the record can be mailed facts emailed
and as long as we receive it by the
close of business on the twentieth it's
part of our deliberation and part of our
record again there are people here from
the staff
Hunter and landmarks commission and
others who are here to basically make
this make the meeting run well they're
here if you need any information from
them either get it at the desk outside
or for anyone in the room and with that
let's get started on the public hearing
and Shelly Friedman is the first name I
have on top he is counsel for the owner
and would invite him to come to that
microphone and then after him would be
sharif el-gamal nathan riddle was so far
shystie and that would be the owners
component proceed Thank You mr. chairman
good afternoon commissioner Shelly
Friedman freeburn and God bomb
representing cell properties which is
the owner of the site we're here today
to continue a discussion that began with
the with the Commission and the staff on
January following mr. Kamal's and elba
miles notification from the staff that
the property had been considered in 1989
for designation this was not something
that he understood before he purchased
the property and so we met with the
Commission and we requested that this be
put on a calendar so that pursuant to
your procedures it could be heard and
hopefully removed we are opposed to the
designation obviously because we're here
today looking forward to it being
removed as a a potentially desert as a
designated proposed for designated site
you will hear from mr. el-gamal shortly
you'll also hear from nathan riddle from
a krf who has prepared the material that
you have hopefully that you have in
front of you you also have a letter from
Imam Feisal indicating his regret that
he could not be here today we know that
it is not sufficient to come to the
Commission and say that well you
designated this in proposes a
designation in 1989 and you haven't done
anything with it since and therefore
that is supposed to lead to the
conclusion that it it it should be
passed upon as a
as a individual landmark but the record
here is something that's quite different
the record here suggests that you have
considered this property in one fashion
or another many times since 1989 the
detailed consideration of Tribeca West
first and that being adopted and then
three other Tribeca and historic
districts being adopted shortly after
that this property was on a master list
of those properties that you considered
for the historic district but it was not
included in any of those historic
districts the Commission then broke out
I think somewhere on 25 individual
properties that did not make the
historic districts and considered those
as individual landmarks and this
property was not among those selected
for that list as well and you have
continued to look at the sites in this
neighborhood as individual landmarks as
recently as two years ago without any
reflection or turning back to to this
property for potential consideration so
we think that all of that in total
indicates that is consistent with what
we're about to present to you in our
testimony that this property in your
mind's in the past and now from from our
submission does not rise to the lug your
standards for for individual landmarking
our report will will compare this
property to the other individual
landmarks in and around Tribeca and we
think it falls far short it is not
sufficient for a building to share
generic attributes with other buildings
in historic districts or with other
individual landmarks clearly this
building does share those attributes but
they are neither exemplary or unique or
celebratory or historically significant
to to the extent that the other
buildings that you have proposed for
individual designation in this in this
part of in this part of Manhattan so
we're going to ask the listen carefully
to our a professional testimony and that
you read our our record and that
you conclude that the building does not
rise to the standards for individual and
marketing and that you so is so inform
the property owner so that the this 20
some odd year proposed designation can
come to can come to a conclusion happy
to answer your questions either as a
group or individually thank you okay
thank you very much sharif el-gamal tea
and then Nathan riddle
good afternoon dear honorable honourable
members of the piano I'd like to thank
hunter college for allowing us to use
their facility today please identify
yourself by name please sharif el-gamal
okay thank you guys make sure I'd like
to thank hunter college for allowing us
to use this facility today I would also
like to thank the NYPD NYPD for their
support and for coming out today and
also being a part of this my name is
sharif el-gamal and i am the chairman
and CEO of soho properties the owner of
the site since 2009 I want to thank the
Commission for its time its
administration of the hearing and its
attentiveness to this issue let me tell
you why I'm here I'm opposed to the
designation of 45 park place as a
landmark I could find no evidence of the
Commission's interest in this building
over the five years it took to purchase
it had I been aware of the 1989 hearing
I would have hired a krf then to
research his history I have done so for
this hearing and you will hear from mr.
riddle in just a moment I have done so
having read the report I feel even more
strongly that this building does not
meet the Commission standards as an
individual landmark I say this is a
proud owner of other properties in
historic districts and I value and
appreciate your role in preserving them
this building however was purchased for
the express purpose of replacement just
the word on that I am a member of the
Muslim congregation that prays at 45
park place and has prayed in lower
Manhattan for the past five decades i
was born in brooklyn and raised in
manhattan and long island as a Muslim
American and a businessman I am proof of
the American dream I have worked in
lower Manhattan for many years now and
I'm fully committed to giving back to
this city which has given me so much
indeed many of our supporters stand
behind this project because they
recognize the value of this project to
the future of New York but more than
that I am the father of two beautif
girls I try to spend as much time as I
can with them which is a new which as
New Yorkers know is easier said than
done in this week's Jewish Week
newspaper the daughter of an interfaith
marriage with a Jewish mother and a
Muslim father noted that there isn't a
clear place in New York to learn about
Muslim cultural heritage it is my hope
that this project be kind becomes that
kind of space and more than that a
service to all New Yorkers I want my
daughters to know that giving doc must
be a part of who they are and that being
a Muslim and serving our fellow citizens
goes hand-in-hand I think a lot about
their future and about the future of the
city that they are growing up in we are
honored to have community one the
community one board as neighbors and
friends who have moved me with their
support in the deepest sense of
gratitude and respect their support
testifying everybody will have an
opportunity to testify their support
upholds the values and beliefs that our
great nation was founded upon they have
also voted unanimously to recommend
against landmark status for this
property because they understand the
importance of this project to
revitalizing New York I want to thank
our supporters starting with Manhattan
borough president scott stringer and
Councilwoman Margaret Chen congressman
jerry nadler Governor Paterson Attorney
General Andrew Cuomo Mayor Michael
Bloomberg state senator daniel squadron
councilman robert jackson and all their
respective staff I would I want to thank
the Commission for its time and
attentiveness to this matter in closing
I especially want to thank amount Faisal
Abdullah oof and his wife Daisy khan for
all they have taught me for the wisdom
may have shared with me and the
tremendous personal sacrifices they have
made in working to develop a vibrant
model for a successful and integrated
Muslim American community thank you very
much thank you very much Nathan riddle
Nathan riddle please remind you of the
three-minute rule please good afternoon
commissioners my name is Nathan riddle
I'm an historian and a krf an
environmental consulting firm a krf was
retained to prepare a narrative history
of the property of 4547 park place and
to assess its significance and
architectural historical and contextual
terms in comparison with similar
buildings located within designated
historic districts and similar buildings
that have been designated as individual
landmarks our report has been submitted
to the Commission in summary our report
concludes that the 4547 Park Place
building does not appear to possess a
special character or special historical
or aesthetic interest such that its
demolition with result in the removal of
a building with a unique history or
design in New York City our assessment
is based on the following 4547 Park
Place is a typical store in loft
building from the 1850s the cash
cast-iron storefront stone upper floors
and italian palazzo style are not unique
45-47 Park Place does not represent the
work of a prolific developer and is
consistent with the many other extant
store and loft buildings that were
constructed without a specific tenant in
mind the cast-iron storefront is not
stylistically unique or an especially
earlier late work of Daniel Badgers
architectural iron works further this
building is not unique for its cast iron
storefront or connection to Daniel
badger in general the individual
landmarks reviewed that have some
similarities to the 45 47 part place
building size type style and or age have
some element of significance that is not
relevant to 45 47 park please these
include significant architect excellent
examples of full cast-iron facades
uniqueness in terms of survival within a
geographic location such as on Broadway
or in the financial district and unique
and innovative designs 45 47 park place
is located on the side streets west of
broadway where a number of store and
loft buildings from this era have been
preserved it is not an exceptional or
important example of the italian palazzo
style and was designed and style typical
for its date of construction it has no
design elements that are unusual for its
period and does not include any
extraordinary surviving decorative
ornament it does not have any innovative
design or construction elements and was
not influential in the design of
subsequent buildings it is not
continuously housed any particular type
of business and it is not known to have
historical significance related to a
person or event special consideration
was given in our report to the buildings
at 2325 Park Place which were recently
designated as landmarks and appear to
have similar architectural and
historical characteristics as 4547 Park
Place however the posada 45-47 Park
Place is much more simple than that of
2325 Park Place and does not have the
hierarchy of window ornament called out
in the findings and designation of those
buildings further the cornices on 2325
Park Place are significantly more
detailed than the simple imola cornices
at 45 47 Park Place 2325 Park Place was
also built for the dry goods firm that
originally occupied it who are located
there from 1857 1865 this makes the 45
47 Park Place building a more mundane
commercial building where the property
appears to have been built as a
profitable rental property leased to a
variety of commercial tenants rather
than at headquarters for a prestigious
prestigious commercial firm okay
concluded thank you who's up for chesty
for kiss T chisti however forgive me for
the pronunciation
and then five more names i'll call them
now so you can get ready please for
indulge me for a moment Joan Romanelli
Barbara pallucci Jack Lester maybe you
can line up on that Mike if you don't
mind Sam number okay please proceed on
over here thank thank you very much mr.
chairman and members of the Commission
my name is was up for chisti I'm a
lawyer and direct excuse me one moment
please there's another mic here if
people want to either way i'll call i'll
call the names as i read them out so
whatever's convenient for you please
proceed thank you again mr. chairman and
members of the Commission my name is
Mustafa chisty I'm a lawyer and I direct
the migration policy institute at NYU
School of Law it's unfortunate that your
mom fessel could not be with us this
afternoon you will get it painfully
aware that a very poor substitute for
him but I speak as someone who has
watched him with admiration as he has
led and nurtured more than one
generation of Muslim Americans used the
fart mosque in lower Manhattan as a
place of worship and reflection for more
than a quarter century during this time
we have seen the place of worship as an
evolving picture of Muslim Americans
today it attracts immigrants to those
who have parents are born in the United
States the second generation Americans
it encompasses the entire spectrum
Muslim Americans today from bankers to
lawyers to academics and students the
second point I want to make quickly is
to speak about the importance of the
Interfaith component of the cardova
house I speak here first as a
professional who studies the diversity
of our country interfaith dialogue is a
compelling national interest today with
huge foreign policy implications I also
speak as a member of an interfaith
family I happen to be married to a
Jewish a woman who was born in New York
we have two daughters who are proud to
consider themselves both Jewish and
Muslim
and there are many places in New York
where they can go to learn about the
Jewish heritage but wouldn't it be great
if there's a place where kids like them
and their many of them in New York today
who can come and not meet meet each
other just as Muslims or as Jews or as
or as Christians but as simply as kids
and share their experiences their
stories and their common culture I do
believe their card oberhaus could be a
place like that thank you okay Thank You
Joan romanelli I get I guess I'm
operating under a misconception I
thought that we were coming here to
discuss the landmark status a 45 47 Park
Place proceed I I will now have to
change what I was saying I was prepared
to discuss the Italian Romanesque please
do style building yes uh that was to be
granted landmark status in 89 my
question is why are we waiting 21 years
later to discover whether or not this
building has landmark status 311
Broadway which is the same kind of
building was granted landmark status in
2010 why was this building not given
landmark status at that time when in
fact it was said that there were very
few italian palazzo style buildings that
existed so why do one and not the other
is my question I I'm neither a lawyer
nor am I an architect but I want to know
why Mayor Bloomberg is against granting
this building landmark status I have
never heard Mayor Bloomberg say
I have never heard from Mayor
Bloomberg's mouth why this building
should not be granted landmark status I
speak before you as a concerned citizen
of New York who cares about our
historical history I am NOT here to
discuss anything else emboss can be
built where a mosque wants to be built
there are plenty of the next not the
issue for today's meeting and I hope
that you will only allow people to speak
about landmark Preservation for this
building because that is the point of
this meeting thank you thank you very
much Barbara pallucci well I guess I'm
going to take this a little bit in a
different direction I think that you
guys should grant landmark status to
this building for a number of reasons
not only its architectural value but its
historical value the landing gear from
one of the planes from 911 attack
crashed into that building went through
the roof and down into the basement and
that should be a museum that building
should be declared a museum I've asked
your
proceed I vest your people when we were
waiting outside how do we get 911 era
Ground Zero declared a historic district
and this building should be part of that
the entire area needs to be created as a
historic district you could take Tribeca
south extension and expand upon that and
rename it right or create just a whole
new one but it needs to be addressed I
think it's very important this
commission is the only hope that that
area has to have it preserved and that's
the most notorious attack on American
soil ever we don't know today if there
are parts of human remains in that
building or any of the others so I said
it's not only all of the things that
people can say about the wonderful cast
iron buildings and my personal opinion
is that every one of them should be
preserved every one of them their unique
there a special group of buildings that
are never gonna be built again all right
one lose any of them all right and
income I hate to contradict people but
the gentleman that was here before
talking about it has to be unique it
doesn't have to be a one-of-a-kind in
order to get landmark protection right
it's a cast iron building it's over a
hundred and fifty years old it has a
very long history I don't have to tell
everybody everybody's gone to the
historical society and to you guys and
try to find out as much as we could
about the history of the building to
make presentations yet I was told today
you guys know more than anybody else
about its history so I don't have to
bring that up but again I say it not at
all cast I'm building should be
preserved and I would ask you to
consider that and this building is part
of that group thank you and this
building in particular should be turned
into a museum a monument to nine
11 so that nobody projects thank you
very much Jack Lester jacket buster and
then we're gonna have Sam nunberg and
then I'll call a few more names please
if you'd move away from the mic or we
can go over here if this is mr. Lester
mounted afternoon please members of the
Commission again I would like to thank
the Commission for holding the hearing
and a place where the public can
participate and in in that realm in that
regard of public participation I would
ask that the record be kept open I agree
I've heard what you said about the
record being kept open for one week but
I would ask that the record be kept open
until the full community board has had
an opportunity to consider landmark
status not just the committee but the
full community board and the reason for
that is that since 1989 the community
board has advocated landmark status much
of the research much of the record that
you have has been prepared and worked on
by the community board so give the
opportunity that's deserved let the
community board have a full public
hearing let democracy rule that's the
American Way now I'd like to say that I
represent Tim Brown who is a surviving a
surviving firefighter on September 11 he
was actually there he participated he
was the first respondent
and in the memory of those people who
perished on September 11th and in
respect to the out of respect to the
family families of the victims and the
survivors this building by itself
because of what has been said by the
previous speakers and others deserves
landmark status now this commission is
aware that there's much precedent for
giving buildings that have unique
historical value landmark status putting
aside the architectural value and the
uniqueness that the community board has
worked on there is much precedent for
example the triangle shirtwaist factory
building was granted landmark status
because of the fire that occurred there
that was part of the historical fabric
of this city the Margaret Sanger clinic
was granted landmark status because of
that contribution to to birth control
and all the issues that came through the
right to abortion movement also the
stone wall building because of what that
contributed to gay rights in this city
and the building that was bombed by the
Weather Underground was granted landmark
status if that building could be granted
landmark status why this building which
was directly impacted by the most
momentous event in in the post-world war
two it generation of the city this
building deserves consideration on
historical merit but even putting aside
that there are twenty-two thousand
landmark buildings in this city fully
six percent of those buildings have been
granted landmark status on historical
events alone and what is more important
to the social historical fabric of this
city cultural fabric of this city than
what occurred on September 11 thank you
very much